in Barcelona animal magician Dan Zaleski
is attempting to pull an orangutan with
a disappearing fruit in cup trick love
is fitting you aren't the only one this
clip notched up over 17 million hits you
can literally see the orangutan
processing and it takes him a second but
he gets it so can orangutans understand
magic orangutans share about 97 percent
of their DNA with humans and they're
extremely intelligent they've been known
to imitate human actions and even
communicate with humans by sign language
but importantly this clip shows us that
they also understand object permanence
that means that when you put an object
somewhere it still exists even when you
can no longer see it so when it sees the
cup and the fruit inside it disappear
from view it knows they still exist when
it cup returns to view but there's no
fruit inside it it finds that completely
surprising it produces a laugh face and
this is a face that is very rare and
generally associated with communication
and play the LA face is a positive
response like a smile in fact we may
have inherited our smile from our great
ape and sisters